Who died and put Lucienne in charge?
And what are Desire's, well...desires?
Here's what we know about the ending of "The
Sandman" Season 1.
The final episode of "The Sandman" Season
1 shows the demon Azazel egging Lucifer Morningstar
on, with the hellish ruler plotting to use
the full might of their armies to bring Morpheus
to his knees.
While this strongly hints at a full-blown
war between the demons of Hell and the forces
of the Dreaming, if the show follows the course
of the source material, this subplot will
likely end in Lucifer's retirement from being
the monarch of Hell, perhaps even following
a similar path to that of the Lucifer that
Tom Ellis portrayed in the series of the same name.
Then again, the showrunners may subvert the
expectations of longtime fans, and things
could unfold on the TV show in an entirely
different manner.
In an interview with TV Line, Gwendoline Christie
mused that the idea of losing to Dream must
be "entirely consuming" for the former favored
angel of God, perhaps enough for it to dwell
on their mind and dictate their actions in
future seasons.
The loss in Season 1 could even be considered
the "final insult" for them.
"Well, Lightbringer, it's your move."
Additionally, Christie revealed that her portrayal
of Lucifer wasn't even inspired by Tom Ellis'
version to begin with, despite being a fan
of the latter.
She even avoided watching Ellis' show so that
it wouldn't influence her take on the role,
and instead opted to take inspiration from
assorted material.
Introduced in Episode 1, the Corinthian serves
as a primary antagonist for the first season
of Netflix's "The Sandman."
The Corinthian's apparent obsession with killing
people in the Waking World, and the unmistakable
joy he derives from taking a life, makes him
the ideal season-long foil for Morpheus.
Aside from being an incredibly dangerous opponent,
the Corinthian also represents everything
that stands against Dream's principles.
While Morpheus is all about maintaining balance,
adhering to predetermined roles, and restoring
things to the way they were before his disappearance,
the Corinthian delights in becoming an agent
of chaos and murder on Earth.
He refuses to stick to the responsibilities
he was created to fulfill.
In "The Sandman Companion" Neil Gaiman confirmed
that the nightmare's name came from the word
pertaining to the behavior typically attributed
to someone from the ancient Grecian region
of Corinth: reckless, lacking in morals, and
possessing a distaste for rules.
Given how closely the series sticks to the
events of the source material, it's highly
likely that we'll see the Corinthian again
in a future season, though perhaps not anytime soon.
Despite Dream's proclamation in Episode 10
that the world doesn't need another mouth-eyed
nightmare just yet, the comic book version
of the Lord of Dreams does end up remaking
a more loyal, less petty version of the Corinthian.
The beginning of Netflix's "Sandman" series
shows how Dream was captured by Roderick Burgess
in 1916 and kept as a prisoner in his mansion
in Wych Cross, England.
The ruler of the Dreaming is shown to be unwavering,
ruthless, and inflexible in his purpose as
well as his resolve.
He spends a century in his prison, remaining
completely silent while being guarded round
the clock by Burgess' men.
And when an opportunity to escape arises,
Morpheus swiftly takes it.
However, his quest to bring things back to
the way they were leads him to become gradually
but profoundly changed.
He begins to realize that he has committed
mistakes during his rule as Dreamlord, and
also learns to be less rigid and more merciful.
"It seems I owe you an apology.
I've always heard it impolite to keep one's
friends waiting."
He recognizes the efforts of his librarian
Lucienne to keep the Dreaming running in his
extended absence.
He also accepts the harsh truth that he does
need friends, and even shows compassion in
situations where he would normally make cold
calculated decisions.
In an interview with TheWrap, Tom Sturridge
revealed that he followed two principles in
his portrayal of Morpheus: that his words
are calculated and precise, and that he is
terrifying and authoritative, yet seductive.
This makes the character journey of someone
as set in his ways as Dream so fascinating
to watch throughout "The Sandman."
It's an evolution we're sure to see more of.
For the uninitiated, one of the most shocking
things to come out of the first season of
"The Sandman" is the dream pregnancy of Lyta
Hall, which was somehow carried over to the
real world thanks to Rose Walker's powers
as a Dream Vortex.
Lyta's child was conceived when she and her
dead husband Hector met and made love in Lyta's dream.
In the "Sandman" Season 1 finale, Lyta gives
birth to a healthy child, who has yet to receive a name.
After surviving her ordeal with Morpheus thanks
to her grandmother Unity Kincaid's ultimate
sacrifice, Rose commits to raising the child
alongside her brother Jed and Lyta.
What new fans of "The Sandman" may not realize,
though, is that the series may have actually
planted the seeds of its finale as early as
this sequence of events.
In the comics, the child, who is the son of
established DC superheroes Dr. Fate and Fury,
receives the name Daniel from Morpheus himself.
Through a series of complicated and ultimately
tragic events, Daniel grows up and discovers
that he has the power to cross over to the
Dreaming.
Eventually, he becomes the new ruler of the
Dreaming when Morpheus dies at the hands of
the Kindly Ones, becoming the new "Dream of
the Endless."
Despite the Corinthian's attempts to trick
Rose Walker into using her Dream Vortex abilities
to destroy Morpheus, the young woman decides
to sacrifice herself to ensure the survival
of her loved ones.
She avoids this fate, however, thanks to the
intervention of two characters: the enigmatic
Gilbert, who is secretly an escapee from the
Dreaming called Fiddler's Green, and Rose's
grandmother Unity Kincaid, who takes the Dream
Vortex from Rose so that she could die in
her great granddaughter's place.
In an interview with Popverse conducted during
SDCC 2022, Vanesu Samunyai shared that in
bringing Rose the Dream Vortex to life, she
had to work on building the character's back
story on her own.
This was because they were using an early
storyline from the comics that covered only
a fraction of Rose's development.
She also described her role in a way that
hinted that there's more to come for the character
in future seasons.
Plus, given Rose's commitment at the end of
the series to take care of her brother Jed
and Lyta's currently unnamed child, it's almost
a certainty that we'll see the character again,
maybe even as early as Season 2.
Perhaps her time as a Dream Vortex will come
in handy when she guides Lyta's child into adulthood.
In Dream's absence, the librarian Lucienne
takes it upon herself to maintain order in the Dreaming.
Whereas the other enchanted denizens of the
realm lost faith in Morpheus and left the
kingdom, Lucienne stayed, firmly believing
that Dream would return someday.
When Morpheus finally does make his return,
he starts by being largely dismissive and
unappreciative of Lucienne's thoughts and
opinions.
By season's end, though, Dream places the
day-to-day operations of the realm in Lucienne's
capable hands once again, as he focuses on
creating a new batch of dreams and nightmares.
"Would you mind taking care of things while
I work?"
From the many interactions between Morpheus
and Lucienne throughout "The Sandman," it's
clear that the Dreaming's librarian has a
deep respect and reverence for Dream.
Despite Dream's apparent disregard for her
efforts, Lucienne continues to work behind
the scenes to prevent the kingdom from collapsing.
This is partly because she's aware of the
tremendous weight on Dream's shoulders and
wants to save him from self-ruin.
Vivienne Acheampong, affirmed this in an interview
with Collider, calling the relationship between
the lord and the librarian "very important
and special."
It's almost guaranteed at this point that
we'll see Lucienne in future seasons of "The Sandman."
Unless the series decides to deviate radically
from the source material, the librarian of
the Dreaming will likely continue to be Dream's
most trusted servant.
In Episode 10 of "The Sandman" Season 1, we
see Dream confront his sibling Desire in the latter's realm.
As it turns out, the misfortunes that befell
Dream in the Waking World were brought about by Desire.
In their conversation with the fellow Endless
known as Despair, it becomes clear that Desire
harbors massive enmity towards Dream, and
is willing to do anything to bring the master
of the Dreaming down a few notches.
While "The Sandman" Season 1 doesn't explore
the deeper reasons behind Desire's malicious
grudge against Dream, their heated exchange
during the last episode promises that we'll
see more of this sibling rivalry in subsequent
seasons.
Interestingly, despite the disastrous consequences
of Desire's actions, Dream's sibling doesn't
see themself as a villain, but as the hero
of their own story.
Mason Alexander Park, who plays Desire, states
this in an interview published by FanSided,
adding that the character only really comes
into conflict with their older brother because
of their disparity in morals and character
traits.
Among the seven siblings who comprise the
Endless, audiences have only been formally
introduced to Dream, Desire, Despair, and
Death.
Their "prodigal" brother Destruction was referred
to, but not name-dropped.
"The Prodigal has returned?"
"What?
Oh, him, no."
We don't get to see Delirium and Destiny in
Season 1, but they're bound to show up in
future seasons, especially since Park expressed
their excitement at being part of a scene
where the siblings come together.
Longtime fans of "The Sandman" may not recognize
Gault, who plays a fairly significant role
in the first season.
That's because she's a character created for
the series, combining two nightmares from
the comics (Brute and Glob) while retaining
the same narrative role they filled.
Much like the Corinthian, Gault serves as
an effective obstacle in Dream's way because
she does not want to follow her predetermined
path.
Her desire to become a vision that inspires
hope, rather than one that brings a person's
fear to the surface, which is her actual role
as a nightmare, is what prompted her to escape
from the Dreaming in the first place.
To watch this contrast play out in the few
episodes she's in is a treat, especially because
it doesn't get immediately resolved when she
confronts Dream.
Rather, we see her get her wish in Episode
10 when Morpheus remakes her into a dream,
complete with beautiful wings.
This represents a significant change not only
in Gault, but in the formerly inflexible Dream as well.
In a way, her rebellion helped both of them
to grow.
"I had no right returning here after over
a century expecting everything to be just
as I left it."
Since Gault's character journey has already
come full circle by the end of Season 1, it's
unlikely that we'll see her pop up in future
seasons.
Never say never, though, as her newfound role
and abilities may still play a part in Dream's
future adventures.
Fans who read the source material may have
expected to see some familiar faces from the
DC Universe in Season 1 of Netflix's "The
Sandman."
For starters, two superheroes strongly affiliated
with the Justice League: Mister Miracle in
his civilian identity, as well as the Martian
Manhunter, appear during the first arc of
the comic book series.
The demon Etrigan served as Dream's guide
when he ventured to Hell to retrieve his helmet.
Perhaps most significantly, Morpheus originally
had to fight the DC supervillain Doctor Destiny
to regain the powers contained in his ruby.
The Netflix series does utilize John Dee in
this specific role, but never refers to him
as his nefarious alter-ego.
While viewers cannot be faulted for speculating
that the reason for their omission was strictly
due to various licensing issues, the reality
appears to be a lot less corporate-driven
than that, at least according to "Sandman"
creator Neil Gaiman.
In a 2021 Tumblr post, a fan asked Gaiman
about his decision to incorporate established
DC characters into "The Sandman."
The author responded that while it was his
desire to tap into "the fabric of the DC universe"
while writing "Sandman," the book, for the
show,
"[It] seemed naturally to drift away from
the DC Universe into [a universe] that looked
a lot more like ours."